i can't imagine anyone voting against
the establishment commission
on the greatest assault since the civil
war on the council
the civil war since the civil war
but anyway chocolate chocolate chip
the biden administration not wanting to
focus in on their policies
it's time for investigations gang we
need investigations this is why the left
is so focused in on the january sixth
commission idea okay now the reality is
there are some questions that could be
asked about january 6.
seriously like there was a a three-hour
gap apparently
between when the riots began in the
capital
and when the police actually arrived on
scene when the when
law enforcement arrived on scene to stop
all that what happened during that
three-hour intervening period
we could find out why exactly nancy
pelosi had not wanted
more law enforcement on premises at the
time
we could find out exactly how law
enforcement officers behaved in the
middle of this because there's tape that
has emerged of some law enforcement
officers
basically kind of moving away were they
just trying to funnel people into a
different space like what was going on
exactly okay but what the democrats want
from this night
from this january 6 commission pretty
obviously is to make the 2022 election a
referendum on trump
and to suggest that all republicans are
complicit in january 6th which is why
they're going to make it about
the rhetoric what led up to january 6.
what was the ideology
in people's minds which again is a
crackdown on ideology and a crackdown on
how people think and how people speak
not really an investigation into the
systematic
law enforcement failures that allowed
people to breach the capitol building
okay we didn't have the 911 commission
was really not about the ideological
roots of al-qaeda
it wasn't we knew what the ideal
ideological roots of al-qaeda or the 911
commission report was really about the
systematic law enforcement failures what
exactly happened but democrats don't
want to restrict this
to what exactly happened on that day
they want it to be broader and they want
this thing to take
beyond the boundaries of the year they
would like this to bleed into next year
so they can continue talking about
january 6th
and then they can say listen no matter
how badly we've governed the country
the people on the other side those guys
are the real threats of the country
they're the ones who are truly scary
this is why joe biden continues to
fulminate
over january 6th it was six months ago
order was restored inside of a few hours
and the vote went forward
the only person who was killed was one
of the rioters ashley babbitt
that's the only person who was murdered
on scene well murder is strong who was
killed on scene
okay the the cops who died on who died
there's no evidence at this point that
they were killed on scene by the rioters
so is that i mean george will suggest
that it was comparable to 9 11
in terms of how americans should think
about it that of course is incredibly
silly
911 was a full-scale attack on the
united states that ended with both world
trade center towers collapsing
a a full-scale plane attack on the
pentagon and another plane
being brought down in a field in
shanksville shanksville pennsylvania
and over 3 000 americans dead this was a
bunch of droogs running into a building
and then running out of a building many
of them getting arrested an order being
restored and
all of the processes going on within
like an hour
so not the same but we're going to
continue to focus in on january 6
because if your policies are failing
this is what you do here is joe biden
pushing the january 6
stuff i can't imagine
anyone voting against establishing the
commission
on the greatest assault since the civil
war on the on the capitol
but at any rate i came for ice cream
that's right
the greatest assault since the civil war
since the civil war
like you know how many bombings there
were like every day in the 70s
many of them targeting government
buildings you remember last summer when
two billion dollars in property damage
was done by rioters in major cities
around the country
remember that and what what in the world
okay but we know what in the world and
that is political misdirection
the media are fully invested in this
they are pointing out
which republicans are are supporting the
nine uh
the one six commission those would be
susan collins lisa murkowski and mitt
romney
have also have all said that they are
supporting that is not a shock of course
then there are about nine republicans
who are still considering
that that would include shelly moore
capital of west virginia bill cassidy of
louisiana mike crapo of idaho
jerry moran of kansas rob portman of
ohio ben sasse of
nebraska john thune of south dakota
patsumi of pennsylvania and roger wicker
of mississippi joe manchin said today he
thinks there may be five or six
republicans who are in favor but a lot
of republicans are not
when asked if he would break the
filibuster if he would vote to nuke the
filibuster in order to get the 1-6
commission
manchester was like nah i don't think
that's appropriate
would you be willing to break the
filibuster in order to get this passed
the claim
destroy our government i'm not going to
destroy my government now i think the
people will come together
you have to have faith there's 10 good
people okay and if there aren't 10 good
people
in his view if there aren't enough
republicans then guess what democrats
will launch their partisan commission
anyway
i mean we all know where this commission
is going don't we the whole point of
this is to keep trump
front and center in the american public
imagination
that is the entire goal here because we
kind of know what we were going to know
and the only stuff that we don't know
could have been found out by democrats
during an impeachment inquiry which they
decided not to do
in favor of rushing that thing forward
so they could get an impeachment on the
books so nancy pelosi could claim she'd
impeach trump twice or something
as though she got extra points meanwhile
if you don't like that investigation
they've got other ones on the way
according to the new york times federal
prosecutors in brooklyn have been
investigating whether several ukrainian
officials helped orchestrate a
wide-ranging plan
to meddle in the 2020 presidential
election including using rudy giuliani
to spread their misleading claims about
president biden
and tilt the election in donald trump's
favor according to people with knowledge
of the manor
more investigations into ukraine and
russia sounds great the criminal
investigation which began during the
final months of the trump administration
and has not been previously reported
underscores the federal government's
increasingly aggressive approach toward
rooting out foreign interference in
american electoral politics
much of that effort is focused on
russian intelligence which has suspected
ties to at least one of the ukrainians
now
under investigation now you'll recall
that the entire russia
collusion investigation came to nothing
after
years of the media pumping it get ready
for more of this now the suggestion is
going to be that russians operating
inside ukraine were trying to skew the
2020 election
now you'll recall that there was no
investigation into ukrainian efforts to
skew the 2016 election why
because the ukrainians were on hillary
clinton's side
this is from politico january 2017.
donald trump wasn't the only
presidential candidate whose campaign
was boosted by officials
of a former soviet black country
ukrainian officials tried to help
hillary clinton and undermine trump by
publicly questioning his fitness for
office
they also disseminated documents
implicating a top trump aiding
corruption
and suggested they were investigating
the matter only to back away after the
election
and they helped clinton's allies
research damaging information on trump
and his advisors
a political investigation found a
ukrainian-american operative who's
consulting for the dnc
met with top officials in the ukrainian
embassy in washington in an effort to
expose ties between trump
top campaign paul manafort and russia
according to people with direct
knowledge of the situation was there a
federal investigation into that no
no so more investigation by the way
there are certain investigations they
are not happy about the democrats
some of those investigations include
like the only important investigation
internationally right now which is
whether kovid was
leaked from a wuhan lab that is
important because we need to know
when the chinese government knew about
kovid if they knew about this thing in
november
and then they waited until late january
to announce that it was humans of human
transmission
not only are they responsible for the
leak they're responsible for the three
million dead people across
the world and the nearly six hundred
thousand dead people in the united
states
and yet there's a certain lack of
curiosity when it comes to our media
and the lab leak theory and the chinese
cover-up a complete lack
of curiosity for example dr ezekiel
emanuel
who is an advisor to to joe biden and a
former health policy advisor in the
obama administration he was on msnbc
saying who cares how it happened why
does it matter the answer is if you want
to stop this from happening in the
future
maybe we should know how it happened
also you might want to punish the
government that hit it for months here
with zika manual being an idiot
we need all the data and we need
transparency and we do need the chinese
to participate because
you know the real issue is not how did
this happen the real issue is
how do we protect ourselves from the
next pandemic
uh and how do we have a kind of early
warning
system uh for whether it's naturally
occurring or
a laboratory leak we still need to
protect ourselves so we don't have
three four five ten million people die
unnecessarily well one of the ways that
you protect yourself is by finding out
whether chinese labs were
engaged in the sort of sloppiness that
allows a deadly virus to leak from the
lab
and then maybe you don't fund them right
then maybe you don't trust the chinese
when they tell you there's no human to
human transmission taiwan didn't trust
the chinese
they had very few deaths south korea
didn't trust the chinese hong kong
didn't trust the chinese government
the the amazing lack of curiosity on the
part of these
public health experts it's shocking
except for the fact that
anything that doesn't abide by their
agenda is just ignored
by them which is why we spent a year
with social media shutting down
any sort of speculation about the lab
league theory
now and now only is facebook deciding oh
yeah i guess you can talk about that
publicly now
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wear are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe
ring that bell because you're not going
to want to miss a single moment